what's up everybody right now here with
sneako so you guys know who he is we're
just gonna answer some questions from my
story about content creation marketing
and online business so first one is and
we got questions from the creativity kit
people it's still we're check the
Discord so I don't know if you're gonna
put the link in description but yeah we
have uh four professors from the
creativity kit in here two editing
professors in the backs of Kevin Bronson
and we have Sunny Faz the content
creation slash marketing Professor the
creativity kit and yours truly sneako
you already know yours truly so first
question that was a fire intro right now
okay go ahead I'm cooking he's cooking
up how do you get ideas for your videos
and streams you can answer this one
first and then I'll go how do I get
ideas for videos and stream streams you
have to stay tapped in to culture they
have to stay it's different
um yes like right now okay if you go for
videos like can you turn the camera I
can show where we are we're in our
biggest fan I don't know if you can see
that Star Wars like Tatooine looking
architecture over there it's bright as
well yeah
you need to do a course on learning how
to use a camera we have four YouTubers
in this car are like in the none of them
even know how to use this camera
properly but
I'm in Marbella because or we're in
Barbados because to get ideas for videos
it gets stale when you're in the same
place when when you say stagnant I don't
get any new ideas you're around the same
people you're having the same
conversations you get in that comfort
zone space and then you're not going to
get any new information new ideas you
need to actively challenge yourself
that's why we're it's it's beautiful
right now that he doesn't know how to
use a [__] camera but it's beautiful
here there's the mountains everywhere
um where we're reading new books we're
driving to Granada to go and and see I'm
buying tickets to do like activities in
the day the only purpose is to get new
ideas for streams for example at
breakfast I'm looking at people people
who are tagging me in their Instagram
story I'm seeing what's going viral like
what people are saying in the comments
what people are what's trendy what
people are talking about you have to
stay tapped into the Normie culture
because if you're not then you're not
going to know what to talk about on
stream stream is five hours of uh just a
stream of Consciousness it's just you
talking Non-Stop and for to keep people
interested you need to talk about
current events a lot of people talk
about basketball stuff like that I don't
like to go that normally but
tune that part of your brain off I get a
lot of people who ask that question
they're very similar they want to get
into this stuff and that they believe in
the red pill and seeking truth and they
think that people all NPCs you can think
that way but you need to tap into NPC
culture to get their attention so get
that idea out of your head that you're
different or you're better than other
people
consume Normie culture
consume normal culture for streams
something that I do is since a lot of
it's reaction based I look at what other
people in my Niche are doing so like I
have a whole list of other content
creators that are pretty similar to me
so like Ben Shapiro Candace Owens
obviously you Matt Walsh because all
these people do reaction stuff you said
all the daily wire people whatever the
[__] but like all those kinds of like
conservative reaction guys so then what
I'll do when I want to make a video is
I'll go to all their channels and I'll
analyze what they posted recently and
all the best performing ones I'll just
steal what they reacted to and just do
it myself that way I'm not doing the
testing process of oh is this going to
do well they're doing it for me and I'm
just plucking it it's funny I actually
do that with your channel as well yeah
sometimes when I'm looking for my
discord's light there's not a lot of
videos to react to I look at like what's
popular from your channel and then
because you're very algorithm minded so
I know I could just like steal ideas for
you if you're reacting to top 10 most
Haram things like that's probably gonna
do well uh it doesn't translate 100 my
audience but it's a good way to yeah
everybody does that everybody takes
ideas from other people yeah so then
well yeah that's a big thing is you know
analyzing what other people in your
Niche do well and either taking some
inspiration copying it or just doing it
better but um for actual videos and the
more creative style I definitely
recommend getting away from devices and
really just trying to be alone with your
mind a lot of the time that I write
these scripts and stuff it's just when
I'm walking my dog I get an idea and
then I just sit down and type in my
notes tab for 20 minutes straight it's
um
yeah I talked about this in a recent
video though like
you know your mind's constantly
distracted by your phone so that's why
people like they're looking at Twitter
Instagram all day every time they have a
hard thought so the only good ideas they
feel like they're getting is when
they're doing something like walking
their dog or they're in the shower or
right before they go into bed because
that's the only time you give your
chance your brain the chance to actually
think but you can space that out more
throughout the day would you agree
what's the first thing you did this
morning bro bro bro bro what's the first
step that's that's not a first of all
that's not a common habit but I was
looking at text I wasn't just scrolling
but I do like though because okay so the
truth is this first thing that Sunday
was there I woke him up today and he was
uh he just started scrolling immediately
but show me your background what is this
what does it say this is a good way to
get your mindset correct all right we
have wake the [__] up
because I don't like looking at my phone
first thing in the morning that is a
habit I'm pretty strict about push-ups
read goals read my villains list if you
guys haven't watched the Tate iron mind
course definitely recommend it
basically just competing with the
version of yourself who you could be
like in Fight Club how it was what's the
[__] guy's name Tyler Durden
competing with Brad Pitt that but Brad
Pitt was himself the whole time that's
your villain and
journal and don't let them win that's
the [__] big one everyone has haters
people always ask what's my inspiration
and [__] and it might sound a little
cliche but it's definitely proven people
wrong in my past would you agree or
yeah that was that for a while but now I
I think it's always you versus you
um that I think that's leads an ego
that's the ego fuel journey and you know
I already did that it already surpassed
them so yeah you know it's not really
that's not how I'm driven anymore I
think it's just should constantly be
challenging yourself you should set up
goals for yourself so Kev asked me a
question this morning like at breakfast
you're like what are your goals and I
couldn't give them anything specific I
mean there's number goals that I have
but
there's nothing extremely concrete and I
need to detail that because if you don't
have any goals in your they're living
life aimlessly yeah well I have a few
different types of goals so at the start
of my journal I have the 2023 goals
which are the more broad ones like a
million YouTube subscribers six figures
monthly 175 pounds so it's just the go
the end goal but not the steps to get
there and then I have monthly goals
which are like actions that take me
closer to that overall goal so like for
the 175 pounds thing it's like all right
eat 200 grams of protein every day and
250 uh push-ups or something like that
or for you know the the one million
YouTube subscribers apart post every day
and make sure you're posting three
pieces of short form content on every
single platform because those steps take
you closer to the overall goal here's
another tip when using the trusty
fisheye lens pan back and forth between
the people that are talking can make
some more engaging okay
we said it was holding a stationary
next question
how to start a business and investing
with 1K
don't like don't just like if you have
1K don't just start thinking that you're
gonna invest it and flip it immediately
I think the best investment uh people
think that there's like some Drop
Shipping blah blah and yourself my boy
yeah invest the best investment is in
yourself so it's not anything specific
that I can tell you but whatever you do
or whatever can make you live better and
work better that's the best investment
for example if you could spend that
towards a laptop or a camera or whatever
you're working on use that money to just
the 1K is not enough to think that
you're going to diversify be smart
though so like
with fat G for example he got a good
amount of money after the videos but he
bought like air pods and multiple
different cameras and it's like
you gotta you know you got to analyze
what you do need like if you have one
good camera you don't need four other
lenses you know you have you have enough
to get started and make money
um but yeah I mean the first program
that I ever bought when I think I only
had like a thousand dollars to my name
was one of those Forex the Forex guys
did you have those in Connecticut we
making money online I'm an I am full
I've never gave money to those people
well I was a bit of an idiot back then
there was some kid from my physics class
who started posting about making money
it was right when I started Tick Tock
and [__] so I was like all right why not
I'll try it
did you ever hear about the thing boom
right there and then you go back on like
think about like a sitcom the way that
it goes back and forth between the you
can make your own you can edit it in
real time like this yeah do you see what
I'm doing
isn't it way more engaging like this
good tips right here
say the funniest word to come to your
mind right now
it's not allowed on YouTube
say the word right now don't let that go
he was looking at the n-word I knew it I
heard it I I I was telepathically I
heard you say something racist nah man
you're tripping I've never said it in my
life
but yeah I know the first [__]
program I ever joined it was like
300 for that Forex [__] and yeah I mean
I didn't learn how to make my [__]
seven percent a day like they're saying
and whatnot but I did take habits out of
that like journaling and what to look
for in a program because at the end of
the day money isn't made it's taken
so they did some things that made me
want to give them my 300 so I sat there
I analyzed what did they do what
marketing tips were they persistent with
reaching out to me did I have more of an
emotional connection what strings did
they pull to get me to pull that trigger
on buying it and then you're able to
translate that into your own content
your own businesses so even though the
overall idea might have been a scam
there's always something you could take
away from stuff so that's why I always
recommend investing in yourself books at
the start I always I think that's a
that's a great way to begin
and programs joining joining stuff like
the creativity kit it's a great way to
start
um and one of the first servers that I
was doing affiliate marketing for did
you ever really get into affiliate
marketing no so I was doing Tick Tock
marketing and I was getting like 200 per
thousand invites I got to the stock
server which is I was getting raped at
the time but I didn't realize it
I got them like 15 000 members probably
made them like minimum 10K mrr and I got
like a couple grand for it but wow yeah
I got raped but it is what it is but
from that server even though I was
making broken money there I met the
other best affiliate marketers who are
also doing organic Tick Tock marketing
and then a few months later when nfts
came around I was able to start the
biggest nft page with these two guys and
then generate millions or organically
doing that so there's always Silver
Linings to stuff and you just got to
keep pushing forward but always
recommend investing in yourself stuff
like one thousand dollars it's not worth
it starting an Ecom store and then
worrying about ads you want to find ways
to learn skills like organic marketing
you know you can get millions of views
for free on Tick Tock right now you
don't need to spend 500 testing this ad
when you only have a thousand dollars to
your name it doesn't make any sense
that's a good point that that's an
underestimated thing uh to invest in is
learning a skill I think people think
that people want to get money really
quickly but the best way to have
long-term money they can't take it away
there's no scam involved that's the best
way to have money for the rest of your
life is if you develop skills that make
you valuable for example I was just
thinking now I mastered this camera for
example at filming at an age where I
could be a filmer right now like if I if
I lost everything if they banned my
Rumble I could be a filmer and I know
the camera better than anybody else in
the car I if I got if I was lost ability
to hold the camera I could become an
editor and I'm a proficient editor
because I mastered a lot of skills that
takes around content creation that will
no matter what happens like I'll be able
to work and no it's a good point so like
don't try to make money just immediately
right now uh think about the long term
because not everything I think everybody
had their idea warped out money
especially because of how many people
you see online that got an nft pump or
whatever crypto stuff like that they
think you could get rich now John they
see Millionaires and they think that
that's attainable for most people and
the truth is it's not so just develop a
skill that's the best investment well
the thing is too you develop that skill
now once the next nft wave the next
crypto wave comes around you're gonna be
the first one on it and you're gonna be
more prepared because you've learned
this skill compared to if you just sat
there with your thumb up your ass the
whole time
yo
huh
what'd you say
what I was gonna say something else
we're getting better at the panel that's
good okay next question we're cooking
you guys hear anything to add
oh sorry
um why they're editors yeah it's just
chills
um I had something else oh yeah yeah so
like I was talking about
so even though the majority of my money
was in the nfg space which is dead now
the reason I made all of that was from
organic marketing so even though you
might look at me and be like oh look you
just made that like what do you know
about business likes Nico was saying I
can translate those same exact skills I
used to blow up that account into
anything else I want I could start a
window washing business I could start a
[__] broom business I could start
whatever I want be able to make content
organically with these same skills and
blow up any business it's the same way
that I've been able to gain 400 000
subscribers in under a year on YouTube
yeah now that's actually insane how many
subscribers you have because it's a
testament to how good you are with the
algorithm and what you learn from your
your affiliate marketing and all the
other work you did it took me like to
get to 400k like four or five years and
it's because I was just going with the
let me make videos and not studying the
algorithm not thinking about the
marketing just trusting that people
would find it but I think it's proof
like the difference in how quickly we
blew up how important it is to study the
marketing yeah I'm a little unorthodox
like I try to go for viral hacks right
away which you know not everyone can do
like you definitely need to be
persistent and keep grinding with the
content you're passionate about like the
first account that I blew up like I said
it was about stocks crypto Finance back
in early 2021 the only reason that I
started that was because GameStop and
that [__] was trending I didn't know a
[__] thing about stocks I would go on
Twitter and look up someone's analysis
and then I would just turn that into a
tick tock but because I have that young
little Ecom phase people were trusting
me but rather than just like I said sit
there with my thumb up my ass copying
tick tocks I bought books and I became
that Finance guy even though I didn't
know anything at the start within a few
months I was the most financially
literate person from my hometown if
people were coming to me for crypto
advice all this [__]
and then I can ask one thing I was just
reading about reproving some book is
it's all about the intention of what you
do like everyone who has money or like a
thousand dollars yeah 500 in this 500
and that it's more so about working on
yourself the skills like snico said
sneako was working on YouTube he had a
million subscribers on YouTube but he
wasn't really making as much money as he
is now he spent almost 10 years building
the skills to make the money he's making
now you have to live what you do so
we're really working on the scales
holding on those skills spending that
money on yourself to build those skills
is the most important things if you want
to make videos if you want to edit spend
on editing software spend that on camera
you don't need too much just keep
working keep doing what you can do and
uh making opportunities out of that
wcab you know what I heard you say once
was you used to feel like um bad about
making money off of YouTube yeah why why
was that like how did your mind shift
since then
um because I just saw it as like as a
form of expression and not a business
and that I didn't want to it just comes
from woke garbage just like making money
spent the same type of ideology where
people say that there's there's no such
thing as an ethical billionaire the
other is like you you want to get to
that point I was just a little bit
brainwashed about
um like making like capitalism's bad and
all this [__] this is one I I it is
weird they have like an agenda against
rich people even in the movies and stuff
you can see that they're always trying
to paint them as the bad person and it
makes perfect sense because you want
people to feel content with being like
brokies yeah and they they brainwash you
to get angry at the famous rich people
and not the actual rich people the real
rich guy I know you even know their
names like you think Elon Musk is really
the richest person in the world now it's
a Rothschild it's one of these old
Legacy families with money from the way
back in the Freemason days like they
that's who really controls the wealth so
don't think that it's the guy you see on
Twitter all the time that's 100 not the
richest person in the world yeah it's
[__]
what if my parents wouldn't let me not
go to college is it a waste of time for
real I can let you answer this one first
it's a waste of time yeah and just don't
listen to your parents
because I went to college because I
think if you don't know what to do
there's at least a community aspect in
college a lot of these guys you got to
consider like kind of losers
you know where there's better ways to
find communities faster and actually
narrow it down because the community
aspect in school a lot of it is Greek
life or it's partying it's just people
drink it all the time a bunch of retards
in a dorm and the only thing they have
in common is alcohol that's that's it's
actually a terrible place to find a
community it's better to find a Network
online where you can really narrow it
down to be around people that you have
common interests with don't go to
college if you don't know what you want
to do complete waste of time no no yeah
that's a good point because even though
I went to to college for the first year
um and then I became successful in
business like November of the first
semester
um it wasn't from anybody that I met at
school it was totally from the people
that I met online and if anything it
sounds like this car look who's in the
car right now does anyone here from my
college Bros again what are you talking
about bro I have friends who make over
300K a year they've been great
School in Canada so I have to worry
about tuition and all that it's pretty
cheap if you have to worry about
spending thousands of us instead of
eight years it's not even about money
you know it's more valuable than money
is time and if you're spending four
years to be around people just for the
aspect of fake evolution of community
money from this job and my Normie job
now so I got two jobs
okay what does that have to do with the
question I'm just saying it could be
valuable for certain people it's not
don't go there if you don't know what
you want to do it's not worth it anymore
with the power of the internet there's
absolutely no reason to go to school
especially if you don't know what you
want to do don't waste your time uh and
if not the money even if it's free don't
waste your time in a place where you're
not going to find what you want all the
classes and courses were developed in
the 70s for example like I wanted to get
it to film and stuff like that the TV
course was developed in 1970s nobody
watches TV anymore everybody's on our
phones but it happened everything's
moving too quickly for them to adjust so
the information is online the
community's online don't go
yeah I mean and then every time you say
this like but we need doctors we need
lawyers it's like no [__] [__] if you
want to be a doctor or a lawyer you have
to go to college each question doesn't
want to be a doctorate lawyer yeah
exactly you want to be an entrepreneur I
always say this the best way to learn
business isn't to study business is to
start a business this isn't unique to me
saying it [__] everyone knows this
there's so many there's plenty of people
that go to school for like a [__]
some [__] degree they leave they
start a business and now they're
successful businessman that's four years
down the drain
good point all right let's get to the
next one what are your thoughts on
YouTube automation versus having a face
Channel
fine it's a good way to make money
um a lot of AIP you can just download
you can go to Wikipedia it just blows my
mind how many people are not doing this
it just seems so easy you can do okay
here's here's a million view video right
now new video game comes out go to
Wikipedia AI The Voice
you hire some guy a Fiverr to edit it
for fifty dollars with some b-roll of
the game boom you could click bait it
put a red circle in the thumbnail
crazy review the Easter eggs in this new
video game question mark exclamation
point boom like that would probably take
you an hour and all the people that have
those channels like there they don't
have any skills that you don't have they
just have a laptop and they know how to
go to these websites it's not hard uh
YouTube automation cool but that's not
why I do it personally but I mean well I
used to I I would definitely recommend
having a face Channel building up your
personal brand building on my personal
brand is my biggest asset right now for
sure because I could lose all my money
but the brand that I have the
connections I've been able to make from
this are they're invaluable for sure and
there's so many benefits to having a
personal brand like
not only can you network with other like
creators but me having 400 000 on
YouTube because I'm a content creator
now status wise I'm the equivalent of
just some entrepreneur making like
Millions a month so now I'm in the same
room as him and then that can help me
with my own businesses
people just want to there's um people
wanna it's easier to find people to work
for you for cheaper because that sounds
bad
no that's just the truth it's true
though like people will work with you
for cheaper even going out with Nico you
just get like free [__] sometimes it's
pretty cool what else yeah personal
brand I think uh it's a it's a
worthwhile sacrifice you do sacrifice
some privacy and hopefully like to your
level yeah yeah you sacrifice some
privacy and then also you makers you get
scrutinized if you get over that it's
really worth it there's a lot of
benefits to it and you've got a lot of
things by growing a personal brand that
rich people pay for for example like I
can go to networking events and stuff
like that for free or people will want
me to come and pay for they want me to
be there because like I'm attached to
something to a brand so I get access to
a lot of things that people with the 10
20 million dollar net worth uh have to
pay for because just me showing up my
face is valuable
um because it's known does that make
sense like it when you grow your
personal brand you yourself become uh an
asset and people want to be around you
then that's that's extremely valuable
thing to have it's nice too when girls
start hitting you up that's a cool
feeling
probably get some DMS all right next
question how much time do you invest
into editing your videos
it depends on the video quite a bit like
yesterday we had a pretty big editing
session we had a Bronson was editing the
Vlogs the cap was editing this uh this
main video
and probably locked in for a couple
hours it's gonna be it's gonna be it
just depends on the video and I can
delegate a lot of the editing to other
people but as much time as it needs
oh you go uh as much time as a niece but
right now we're working like we're in a
Zone with like me and snake love really
built up a lot of creative skill already
so you know if you're starting off don't
rush it there's no reason to rush it you
know really work on the skills that
you're developing don't also put too
much concern in what you're putting out
too like don't be so concerned about uh
you know this is look good at it I just
keep making keep making don't wait too
long to release something just keep
moving yeah definitely I would also say
analyze what your time is worth and if
you can delegate parts of your editing
do so so for example since I'm a
reaction Channel and I'm not as you know
I don't have as much of a creative style
like zico I don't need to be the one
sitting there editing my videos because
I can hire someone for twenty dollars an
hour to do that so sneaker for example
he'll do more editing on the creative
videos that he wants to put more time
into because you know he wants that to
have his touch but with stuff like Vlogs
and reaction videos he'll Outsource that
because you know someone else can do the
job pretty much the same as him all it
is is opportunity cost and cost benefit
analysis
analyzing what your time is worth and if
you can Outsource making that time
more worth it elsewhere do you will ever
have lack of creativity at some point in
life if so how do you deal with it
you went through like two I heard you
say um like two years three years where
you didn't post because yeah it wasn't a
lack of creativity it was uh
just procrastination laziness
and fear of judgment stuff like that it
wasn't
I I you get caught in the comfort zone
that's the when you get used to see when
you don't apply pressure on yourself
like when you're most comfortable enough
in school and in college uh like yeah
I'm in a community I'm like working
towards something like when you get when
you have the illusion that you're
comfortable I think that's one of the
most dangerous places to be in because
you're you're like jello you're just
stagnant not really going anywhere kind
of lethargic in this medicated
vaccinated state of Life uh I don't I
don't recommend that for anybody so the
way out of that is to challenge yourself
and put yourself in new situations and
scenarios having different conversations
uh get actively fight that routine
because I think routine well that's what
I realize is like that's the biggest
trap for the mind is when you get used
to something and you your brain becomes
automated your brain is capable of so
much we're able to there's so much
information out there there's so much to
see there's so much to learn from so if
you're not actively seeking that then
you just get you start looping and no
matter how smart you are or how
interested and curious you are you you
can
get you you could start sinking like
it's like you're standing in quicksand
if you're not wiggling out then you're
not gonna get across the pond was that
cooking that was good that was cooking
did I cook you cooked I zoned out for a
second to add on to that though yeah
when you feel like you lack creativity
just live with it live well what the
[__] when you like me to live with more
intention consider what are you doing in
your daily lives right like are you
going to the gym but what are you doing
when you come back are you scrolling
Tick Tock right if you live without
purpose obviously you can lack
creativity there's always opportunity
for room for improvement getting more
knowledge reading more books if you feel
like you don't know enough you can
always learn enough information is free
you don't have to pay for this stuff
one extra thing I'll add is never try to
be a perfectionist from the start this
is something that I know and I still
haven't practiced this in my life as
much as I want
yeah okay that would that would be a
detriment this is pretty good right now
so even when I had like that first mom
reacts video I had it I had the videos
organized but because you're you're
always overthinking little stuff like is
this setting gonna be off in the YouTube
video is this is this is this in the
camera you overthink everything and then
now it's two weeks later and you still
haven't had it and you still haven't
started on the idea you're worried about
starting your Ecom store well I don't
know if this copy is going to be good
enough or if I should use this picture
it doesn't [__] matter at the end of
the day you're better off just starting
it now learning from your mistakes than
waiting two weeks to try to be a
perfectionist meanwhile you're just
gonna make different mistakes and have
to learn anyways so I would always
recommend starting now even with
vlogging and stuff I've been postponing
this [__] so long I just traveled Europe
and I basically I didn't film as much of
it as I wanted to when real this isn't
[__] hard I'm holding a camera
talking to you guys go like look at me
in Europe like it's not that crazy but
in my mind it was such a bigger obstacle
when realistically like you said you
just got to push yourself out of your
comfort zone and the more you do so the
farther you can keep going what I think
it's really important like we have a the
BNB with the four of us right now and
having somebody like at the smallest
thing Sonny was in Europe for like five
weeks though all we needed was somebody
to hand him a camera and press record on
it and then he's he's making it but he
didn't have anybody to push him and
really uh keep him in that mindset
because he was comfortable around like
[__] in Europe and you know relatives
he's visiting that was the comfort zone
but if around people that are going to
push you it could be something as simple
as handing you the camera and then now
you're working again so keep people
around you that are going to push you
that's that's an extremely valuable
thing to have like the for example this
morning uh if I didn't wake up everybody
at 8 A.M probably would have been
bumming around until like 10 or 11 and
that we would have wasted much more of
the day but even me like I probably if I
wasn't in the BNB with
um all these guys in the car I probably
would have been a little easier too I
probably maybe I would have scrolled
maybe I would have been on Twitter my
computer longer but it's like
everybody's in here they're waiting for
someone to get done I got to figure out
an activity for the day so you
you get you push yourself more when
you're around people who are in a
similar boat or people that are also
motivated let me know what you thought
of the video today there's gonna be a
lot more content like this going forward
Vlogs public interviews just simple q
and A's like this you know I've learned
a lot over business the last few years
from marketing running businesses
managing people networking you know I
only started my YouTube channel a year
ago and we've been able to grow it this
far so I think it's time to start
dropping a lot more value to you guys
rather than strictly doing reaction
videos you know it's also a lot more
fulfilling actually seeing lives change
from teaching you guys [__] but uh
yeah let me know what you thought make
sure you turn the Bell on right [__]
now because we have crazy videos coming
up and yeah
see you later boxing with stick a lot
next I believe peace